[music]
[applause]
thank you do not the machine here
that was from us the most of you told
commodore 64 of mind institute itri
schuster the going altenauer dsds to
vienna compared to day skepticism the awo 64
kilobyte of memory the floppy  disks
cousteau bonn hundred seventy kilobyte
and no one knows what has also been a
dual core version of the world of the
blue course and looked like the lancet
resources before used the picture 752 es
before your houston teenager claims
an indian version of rochester
fraction of for  your children of the
married couple true for the music is the big
challenge roberts resources not big it's
you any more days to pick us about
complexity complexity because systems
allerding b and bgn somehow how did
you play the role of fast die in and
old as well as have to deal  with the
different teams like the association on
teams like booklets coordinates for have to
care about long time and ability to
business software software and even more
like th  e product of the velvet of the
milk production lasting state office
javascript something like that would have training built
manzako and airbus event theater was using the
in your team is so much 2015 so just
2015 is just for years and some bonn
is finger pointing to you for using
something that was  quite a nice
technology sector so something that i
will fire manfred train and consultant
on trainings as well as inhouse
consultancy here in germany place also in
austria
and a bad on the google developer
exports are including xml soap operator by
angela and israel a problem saw new
features before the upcoming angela merkels
product is all about angela workshop
about angela in the enterprise and its
contents
the scenario cash content workshop as
well as the public war
let's talk about components web
components of the future
at protect your web components can very
very easy lacen racing  has never been
dead simple as the web components but
the truth is that there is nothing like it
web components because web components
is joked umbrella tors of jobs'
standards it can be used to get to
provide framework ethiopian logos of
standards the prince logo is at tablets
don't need to talk much about tablets
like all no time space and doesn't want any
matching something like xml template
play should the display ports import
something from another thing wide web
components the ford custom elements
fiasco
this is the most important standard
here custom elements keeps you babe
roberto nature elements.at ml elements
the process contains both browser
framework agnostic and  data domain
really like to print you den german or
to use the german expressionism shadow
dome with sounds made in germany us trials
shadow domatter next meeting end of the
strike cost shadow maps youtube
kappel element fromm the rest of the
dome so element calendar spread le pen
the dispute in new york critical naldo
and admins of the sc ssv component does not
effect the  rest of the application
mode situation
you have to success 4 you try to you
stay together and the moment you
stay together hell brakes los the exact
situation is expected at Schatten dom
so most it's like can
immediately forget about eml imports day
will not be a fence off and or the top
ott implementing it because they say
they have something like that i have no
script imports usetec moskau 2005 and
pickup service raptors import statements
the film i'm getting a square talking
about is in the enterprise ireland
the taste of the work together with no i
is stepic caught in the enterprise
environment got softball i feel a
wholly policies in ordos composer a
first approach is not used to be
free the apa levels of course so
perfect and of course i have to arrange
yourself to believe what would you do this
and then you started as early as most of
the things that work if you look at
the power of custom elements you see is
really drop  dead simple the topic whether
classic the element end of
euroconstruct all you can create the
dome is adom uk its element tm
just singing all for take-off simplicity
of the notary performance way to provide
saturday party the simple is one of the best
for getting started a custom element
the browser will take care about us sing
you think of the elements is simple in
free practice i have built to take care about
the binding updating the eu and
about things like that the
wille der gangen sie in jackson hensel 12 am
really happy that a lot  of national
frameworks out that help to get started
with custom elements lower court in the
world of health it and component in front of the
browser when looking into the world you
can use it components
when it comes to react as a message for
you think you can rap correct
components just  use tp webzine before
and in the middle of the constructor
you could put the perfect components
oder also community solutions does ist
switch fram  e rock you sing you can use
web components so it people before web
components is the princess wanda talk
about the second quarter from youtube
something like your mind and agility is
simple is and epic system that can do
everything goes when your system
got violently suite difficult  to maintain the
true teams in wolfs teams gets into the
situation of have to talk with each
other
tag like feature the skating talking with
each other communication is further bad
sachsa setting can so let the
situation be forst in the blog of sec
and him be sec and  in the basement start
implementing cannot get the blue something
have to wait for data teams and
the steaks outletcity er according to chile the
flexible the end zone tables of the user
have one framework and of architect
josef von system and profis hart change
you try to change framework if you try
to change architect jo jo relling from how
frankenstein monster you don't want to
have
and if you finke bot long-term
inte  rner bild.de that is further the
costs no one knows what we will have
completed completely different because of the
possibility to change a thing in the
speed week must-see pixel
dark x11 content magazins people and
services and technologies technologies
put
fitz best for the current  Needs you have
les coordination team center es complex
because of small applications of course
which is nothing to just comes with one
touch es when until when the referees who designs
the ending compartments distributed systems
distributed age of this
application scanning to the data base of the
s11 content application and  i have to
deal with my compensation composition
means that you have to present
eric baumann catches the user via happy to have
fifty tennis complex applications the
user is the user is not interested in
the starting with the application and
need to present everything is coming to
him
kick-off in the julia so if built
compositing very simple approach might
be using hyperlin  ks hyperlinks majors knees
around for two years now the world
wide web is what you think it's quite
the major technology cuxhaven never ever
heard the saying scenario of an
application connector toyoda by means of
haifa links and not des sounds am
nordbad for some crimes of applications
des  solution especially for product
suite google street view had google
street view have something like google
maps the specialized enduro news
network routes to switch to the application
creates follower hyperlink here on
ebay the slideshows the most important
aspect of the presentation putting
out of the seas  intuitively you forget
everything is always remember this time
aspects of the very berry next
here in germany to be more praised in
lower saxony the village scott steinberg
am very proud of your sex uniform
lower saxony yalla few people think you
can hear the advantage of using
hyperlinks ist ob  the simple statement
from sony about the eagle application and
you'll h  ave to guiden using the
application svenja follower hyperlink
this exactly the wanted to prevent
if like in windows application city also
have to take care about you
consistency lower court would like to
switch it looks to say that calls for
you can use of the mails or services
application  cache label offloading or
single bubbly patients with what is the
most respect before writing application der
disco floating
with the element phosphor to thank you
the strange villingen testament if
one hearing the word iframes but
sometimes it solutions frame provides
the amount of solution that means one
iframe  cannot hacker iframe budgets
weidl if you have to integrate several
applications from the event is also a
few does not influenza functional
tk branch sports tracking tracing beach
application switch means i have one in the
backstage painting of youload several
single page applications denkel
application application application case
youtube user test store app  everything
in the web components duo robbery micro
web components new software exchange
web components portis comes with the big
one touch way you have for unified ip
before the head of the skull does not need
to know how you would think and have to
talk with you that way  and your
application ins orf to talk with you
were just have unified ip that provides
properties and events and so josef
unified communication micro apps and web
components all things that means you can
use angela component in the middle of
wrecked component video you sing in the
middle  of the few composes when julia
is the architect holding troops enter
unfortunately the layer brings widgets at
college slayer or michael jackson becomes
the second sector stars you can come up
with completely different solutions for
each of the day on the market
you could use hyperlinks you  could use
web components you could you think it
applications of rap combo after florida
demonstration before the end of the
demo  nstration forth sella
british namely in a click here im blood
in angola application and also luding
angola application das separat
applications application stack and
develop bradley button bradley end
stayed start date stand alone mode
association just lotus applications es
web components and displays dem here also
have you  components smells like can
mix and match different technologies and
have a ligist the application angela
jazz application dies shows that you
can use to me the way from liga sie
technologies this topic integration in
the center of his salon cases
ok we have several approaches for
providing microsoft javascript
technologies endlauf kolster
squeezing it is the stimulus solution for our current
needs to be a mass destruction is very
difficult to ansa because of time has
come adventures and some of which is one
of the founders this casting
thomas had monday he came up with the century
fox  solution of course we cannot be jus  t
want to have a lot of state have to
navigate eliot between your say no
dances of the best of haifa links in the
case of difference 11 content
applications and you can integrated
tampa links lets the ist im lot of
state of the art of navigation between
marc rath the next question is to you
have to integrate lie you applications
to you need a very strong isolation
and justin theroux iframes blessing of you
will not right the next amazon.de frames
the motto good as you know for public
website is okay me  before intranet style
applications 14 o emphasizes
the starting and the greenfield more frequently because the
next question is to you even the parade
planned
do you can have several things to you i
beni the mix of technology and if
uci yesterday cleaning crews server single page
impressions for say  no to be for mono
repository
application data provided using
libraries in a japanese moritz the
best thing you can make use of web
components ok let me come to the
con  clusion we draw the web components
helbach mare kappel from egg current
framework develops micro apps help us
with big apple in between teams a
project teams the scan to the decisions
we are how can complete municipalities are
micros form something beautiful like
autumn using the broadway one of  us can
use the best technologies for car and
project
[applause]
[music]